ideally you start early because I think
at age six or seven the kids could learn
more about the World by playing chess
chess brings some unique qualities to
any kid it's not about being the
champion but it's about learning
self-discipline just learning something
about logic
learning about your own attitude and at
the end of the day learning about
responsibility because that's very
important sense of responsibility that's
what is being missed now all over the
place and in chess you have no one to
rely on I mean you you have no backup
it's entirely in your hands
you make a good move you win you make a
bad move you lose so that's a hard
lesson you can take from shares and
that's why I'm a great proponent of
eventually installing chess into the uh
educational system I hope that one day
we could see chess in every classroom
worldwide because for very little
expense with a you know it's you don't
need the soccer field or tennis court
for the very little expense you can
install something that could help kids
to improve their performance in the
general curriculum so I would encourage
anyone to teach their kids playing chess
thank you
Daddy castano thank you very very much